Music Thank you. Ist das ein Fate? Ist das ein Fate, Flotin? Ist das ein Fate in die Folge? Ja, es ist ein Fate. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO mit meiner Wenigkeit Stefan Michael, Mariaav, Tietze und dir, Flo Nibbel. Hallo, schönen Dank für die Einladung. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass ich heute mal mit dabei sein darf. Ich habe dieses Mal keine Lust gehabt, das alleine zu machen, deswegen habe ich dich eingeladen. Du hast zugesagt, hast ja viel Zeit im Moment. Ja. Und vielen Dank an Malte für dieses klassische Intro. Toller, toller Rhythmus, tolle ... Bambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambambhythmus, tolle Bambam, Bambam, Bambam, sind wir da richtig, wir sind ja die Wie-Generation. Wir sind die Wie-Generation. Du hast hier einen Zettel mit Fragen gemacht, oder wie heute? Was? Einen Zettel mit Fragen? Nein, das ist nur mein iPhone. Ach so. Hä, Zettel mit Fragen? Ich dachte, du hast das Ding auf. Wo sind wir hier, bei Gäste, Liste, Geisterbahn oder was? Nein, wir machen hier keine Fragen. Das ist hier noch Impro. Good old Impro. Ich habe nichts aufgeschrieben. Hast du diese Doku gesehen? Mit den... Nee. Ja, ich habe es auch noch nicht gesehen, aber nächste Woche vielleicht, wo ich die angucken auf Netflix. Nee, tatsächlich, wir sind hier beim das Podcast-Ufo, wir improvisieren das Gespräch noch, bei uns gibt es keine Fragen, die wir uns auch beschrieben haben. Von Hand improvisiert noch. Von Hand improvisiert noch, nach den guten alten traditionellen Improv-Regeln. Ja, seit 2014 sind wir mit dabei. Was ist hier los? Das bricht auch bald zusammen, ne, dieser Bunker, in dem wir hier sitzen. Ja. Draußen wird noch viel gearbeitet. Wir haben mittlerweile schon so viele Podcasts gemacht, bei uns ist ein Kabel kaputt gegangen. Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass das passieren kann. Doch, wir haben eine Halbwertszeit
von, glaube ich, 200 Folgen und dann
ist es vorbei. Und wir dachten uns 200 Folgen,
mein Gott, dann machen wir vier Podcasts daraus.
Wir dachten ja damals, es wird so ein Shotgun-Projekt
damals. Drei Folgen, Fame,
Podcastpreis und wir gehen nach Hause. Das ist
über 200 Folgen, da konnte damals niemand wissen.
Aber wir haben unser Kabel ausgetauscht,
das ist neu, es ist frisch, ich finde,
du klingst sehr... Das freut mich. Sehr gut.
Ich finde frischer. Ich wollte ein HDMI-Kabel
Aber oder folgender Ort konnte damals niemand wissen. Aber wir haben unser Kabel ausgetauscht, das ist neu, es ist frisch, ich finde, du klingst sehr... Das freut mich. Sehr gut.
Ich wollte ein HDMI-Kabel
kaufen und du denkst dir, du gehst zum Saturn und
kaufst den HDMI-Kabel, aber
falsch gedacht, du bist in einer neuen
Welt... Du gehst zu Amazon und kaufst ein HDMI-Kabel.
Du bist in einer neuen Welt?
Du stehst vor einem riesigen Regal.
HDMI-Regal? Mit wirklich fünf mal
zehn verschiedenen HDMI-Kabel und du denkst dir, gut, da gibt es ein HDMI-Kabel kurz, mittel und lang. Nee, es gibt mit Gold und du denkst dir, Moment mal, wie könnte... Sehe ich dann besser? Ja, alles sieht besser aus durch Gold. Aber Saturn-Mitarbeiter sind auf einer Stufe mit Baumarkt-Mitarbeitern. Bitte nicht ansprechen. Steht groß auf ihrer Stirn und auf ihrem T-Shirt auch. Bisschen weird, der Service Approach. Aber die darfst du nicht ansprechen, das ist eine allgemeine Regel, eine gesellschaftliche Regel. Die werden sofort genervt und die helfen dir auch nicht dabei. Total, ich habe mir die HDMI-Kabel angeguckt und dann gehen die ja wie so Ernteroboter, gehen die ja so immer durch die Regalen und füllen die auf, so zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, allem, es ist ja unfassbar, wie viele DVDs es noch gibt. Es es noch gibt, ne? Vor allem, ich habe mir geguckt, bei diesem einen Satur, in einem einzigen Laden gab es noch, ich habe geguckt, die DVD-Boxen von Game of Thrones und die Staffel 1 gab es siebzehn Mal. Siebzehn mal die Staffel eins als Box, als DVD-Box, wo ich mir dachte, es muss jetzt noch mindestens siebzehn Leute geben, die sagen, Game of Thrones sagt mir gar nichts, kenne ich nicht. Ich liebe Ritter und Drachen, ich liebe Drama, aber Game of Thrones habe ich noch nicht gehört. Und die sagen dann auch noch, online gucken, auf Sky, mach ich nicht, kaufe mir die Box. Aber die CD und dann auch die DVD-Box und die Blu-Ray-Box, sondern auch noch ein Step-Back. Weird, und ich stehe vor der großen Frage, was mache ich mit meinen DVDs? Weil die Wohnung habe ich jetzt schon sechs Jahre, die ich jetzt verlasse, und da habe ich jetzt eine Menge DVDs gesammelt und Blu-rays. Und die habe ich jetzt noch, aber die brauche ich ja nicht mehr. Und alles, was ich nichtuche, nehme ich ja auch nicht mit in die neue Wohnung. Bin ich ja bescheuert? Ich habe meine in langem Aufwand alle digitalisiert. Alle DVDs digitalisiert. Und dann weggeschmissen, die Hardware? Ich habe die ganzen Boxen weggeschmissen und die CDs habe ich immer noch aufgoben. Ist Digitalisieren nicht ein Euphemismus für Raub kopiert? Ich glaube, wenn du die hast, weiß ich nicht. Aber vor allem, ich meine, der Vorteil von Digitalisieren ist, du hast halt alle Filme, die es auch auf Amazon und Netflix gibt, aber in schlechterer Qualität und nur mit einer Sprache und so. Also es ist furchtbar. Aber den Audiokommentar von Boogie Nights würde ich ja dann auch wegschmeißen. Du kannst es ja so digitalisieren, dass du den Film nur noch mit Audiokommentar anschauen kannst. Hey, wollen wir uns Boogie Nights angucken? Ja, sagt dir Paul Thomas Anderson was. Der labert da die ganze Zeit drüber, aber auch nicht vorher anmoderieren und dann einmal gucken, was das Date so sagt, wenn sie dann nach Minute 13 irgendwann sich zu dir dreht und sagt, der Film ist ja schon seltsam, dass dir jemand quatscht im Hintergrund oder auch über die Musik und so. Nee, nee, psch. Es gibt ja von, glaube ich, Conan der Barbar ein Audiokommentar mit Aaron Schwarzenegger, wo er Alkohol trinkt und im Verlauf immer betrunken wird und am Ende sich mit Leuten streitet und rumschreit und so. Also das ist eigentlich Best-Case-First-Date mit jemandem auf ein Date und dann einfach schauen wir uns Audiokommentar an. Oder einfach, wie gesagt, unkommentiert, finde ich auch gut. Aber ganz kurz, nee, nee, nee, ist ein Thema. Okay, gut, dann erst mal du. Werden denn DVDs, die nicht verkauft werden, recycelt? Ich weiß nicht, und viele solche Fragen stelle ich mir auch gerade, weil Stichwort Umzug. Irgendwann, also es ist ja alles nervig, alles nervt am Umzug und du willst einfach nur ballastlos werden, abwerfen. Du bist wie so alte Filme, so Piratenfilme, wo ein Schiff schneller werden musste und dann schmeißt du ganz viel über Bord, damit du schneller wirst. So fühle ich mich auch die ganze Zeit gerade. Ich bin auf dem Weg mit meinem kleinen Schiffchen und ich will einfach nur alles über Bord werfen. Und dann habe ich aus meiner Schublade herausgekramt meine alte Wii, wo wir gerade schon beim Thema waren. Meine alte Wii. So, und dann gibt es ja diese Website Wir Kaufen's, wo man Dinge hinschicken kann, die man nicht mehr will. Das Gute ist, man muss sich auch nicht darum kümmern, dass man da alles Sachen löscht und was machen die für einen und so weiter. Ja, oder auch nicht, weiß man auch nicht. Die klauen deine Mies, die Figuren, die du gebaut hast, so aussehen wie die Rebecca aus der Parallelklasse. Und dann machen die so Pornos mit denen, dann stellen die so online, oh Gott, oh Gott, das will ja niemand. Aber dann habe ich geguckt, wie viel ich für die Wii noch bekommen würde, zwölf Euro.
Zwölf Euro. Und dann habe ich die genommen, und das ist vielleicht nicht toll. Und gegen die Wand geworfen. Und einfach weggeschmissen. Ja. Und wenn jetzt, dann habe ich mir so vorgestellt, wie der 16-jährige Stefan neben mir steht und sieht, wie ich diese Wii einfach nehme, nicht immer verkaufe, wegschmeiße. Du kannst ja auch spenden.
Aber an wen denn? Ja, gib die einfach jemanden
auf der Strasse. Wenn die mir die für
12 Euro abkaufen, verkaufen die die
für 15 Euro weiter. Die kannst du
offensichtlich für sehr wenig Geld.
Auf der Strasse, was will denn Obdachloser mit einer Wii?
Ja, Wii Sports,
Tennis. Fit,
fit werden. Aber ich meine, ich denke
bei solchen Sachen. Ich finde es total schwierig, ich habe es auch nicht gern getan. Vor allem, du denkst ja null in Dynastien, oder? Also null. Null. Gar nicht. Nee, gar nicht in Dynastien. Im Sinne von, meine Kinder werden eines Tages mit meiner Wii spielen, wie ich damals. So denkst du gar nicht, ne? Nee, ich denke gar nicht in Dynastien. Null. Dynastien spielen wenig Rollen in meinem Leben. Ja, manchmal denke ich mir so, irgendwas hebe ich auf, um es vererben zu können. Eine Wii? Vielleicht eine Wii, aber gut, die werden es halt auf ihrem Switchphone dann drauf haben. Wie nennt man das? Als Emulgator. Emulgator. Nee, Moment. Doch, Emulgator. Emulgator? Nein, da sind G zu viel drin. Da sind viele Buchstaben zu viel. Emul... Du, ich bin in der Zukunft dann unterwegs. Da verschwimmt alles ineinander. Das war so seltsam. Was mache ich mit der Wii? Habe ich das weggeschmissen? Vielleicht nicht gut, vielleicht nicht richtig. Vielleicht sollte man das auch anders zum Wertwerkstoffhof bringen. Vielleicht kriegt man ja auch nochmal einen Geschwister und kann es dem dann schenken. Mein Bruder hat mir einen Ninja-Stern, einen Wurfstern geschenkt und ich dachte mir, cool, hätte ich einen Bruder, ich würde ihm auch was cooles schenken, aber ich habe keinen unter mir und was will man denn den über einem älteren Brüdern cooles schenken. Das stimmt. Man hat nichts, was die interessiert, weil man auch nur Dinge besitzt, die du von denen hast. Also alles, was du besitzt, haben die schon mal besessen. Interesse läuft ja linear in der Zeit. Außer Lego vielleicht. So mit 40 hast du dann nochmal Bock auf Lego und dann kann der Kind seinem Vater Lego schenken und dann freut sich der Vater über das Lego vom Kind. Aber bis dahin läuft alles nur von oben nach unten und ich hatte diesen Wurfstern, ich glaube es hat ungefähr vier Tage genaut, bis er meine Mutter herausgefunden hat, dass ich einen fucking Wurfstern habe. Ich dachte, dass deine Mutter gestorben ist, weil sie einen Wurfstern in ihr Gesicht geworfen hat. Ich weiß schon mal, dass meine Mutter in den Keller gestürmt ist, angelockt durch das Geräusch von aufeinander klirrenden Schwertern, als ein Kumpel von mir und ich uns mit Schwertern im Keller, im Raum gekämpft haben, meine Mutter und mit so einem, soll ich jetzt noch was sagen oder, also ich meine, manche Dinge muss man Kindern erklären, aber manchen Dingen kann man auch einfach sagen, sag mal, merkst du es eigentlich gerade? Ja, vor allem, ich habe mir immer, irgendwann wollte ich gerne Pfeil und Bogen, ich hatte mehrere Pfeil und Bogenphasen in meinem Leben, aber anders als du habe ich mir das gekauft und nicht im Wald, in der
Badewanne den langen Bogen
geschmiedet, über mehrere
Jahre mit Elben zusammen
und so. Nein, ich bin in den Laden gegangen,
wie ein normaler Mensch. So ein Plastikbogen.
Nee, aber mit so Fiberglasbogen, also der war auch
sehr lang. Boah, die sind aber hart, ja. Die war ganz schön
knallhart und dann
richtig knallhart und dann haben die
aber auch Pfeile, habe ich gesehen, die haben diese typischen
Pfeile mit diesen Noppen vorne, die
an so einem Fenster, die für zwei Sekunden am Fenster
Das ist ein Schuss. und dann, also richtig knallhart und dann haben die aber auch Pfeile, habe ich gesehen, die haben ja diese typischen Pfeile mit diesen Noppen vorne, die ja so an dem Fenster, die für zwei Sekunden am Fenster kleben bleiben und dann runterfallen, die hatten die, aber ich bin ja ein pfiffiges Kind, also habe ich dann auch nochmal untermguckt, weil das war irgendwie so ein Regal und dann gab es da drunter, lagen dann so weiss nicht, noch andere Bögen eingepackt noch und so, da habe ich mal ein bisschen gewühlt, in dem Regal, unten waren dann so versteckt noch mehr Pfeile, aber die Pfeile hatten einfach, und ich weiss nicht, warum man das überhaupt herstellen sollte, weil das waren trotzdem so Kindermaterialpfeile, aber mit einer Metallkugel vorne dran, also mit einer Metallspitze, eine Metall, aber also, eine Metallspitze, sagen wir, wie es das ist. Also keine Kugel. Nein, nein, ich habe kurz in die falsche Richtung genommen, eine Metallspitze. Also keine Kugel. Nein, nein, keine, ich habe kurz in die falsche Rechnung genommen. Eine Metallspitze einfach. Ich erinnere mich an Kugel, weil es war, irgendwann habe ich das so oft gegen eine Wand geschossen damit, dass es dann so kugelförmig wurde. Aber es war am Anfang tatsächlich einfach eine Spitze und es sah aus wie eine Patrone von einem, von einem. Wie eine Kugel ein bisschen. Wie eine Patronenkugel.
Wie eine Pistolen, daher kam es ja.
Wie eine Pistolenkugel. Ja.
Die haben ja vorne auch so, die sind auch spitz. Ja, aber so sah es aus.
Und es ist halt, du kannst damit einfach
jemanden umbringen. Ja, absolut.
Absolut. Es war auch aus Messing, also
richtig krasses Material.
Ja. Warum sollte man das verkaufen
von einem Toys R Us? Ich bin immer noch sehr erstaunt, dass ich meine Kindheit überlebt habe. Mein Cousin hat mir mit einer Metallspinze an die Schläfe geschossen, an die Schläfe vorbei. Und da, wo ich mir wirklich dachte, hätte er ein Zentimeter nach links geschossen, wäre ich wahrscheinlich einfach rot. Das ist auch so ein Moment, wo man kurz erwachsen wird, wo man kurz sagt, nee, komm jetzt. Vorher ist es noch so, ha, Elben, Krieg, und dann passiert sowas, und dann denkt man kurz so, nee warum wir das, lass uns das einfach lassen, lass uns das einfach nicht mehr machen. Du willst die Hausfrau machen und dann würde ich sagen, ist es auch 18 Uhr, dann wurde ich erst mal geblutet, wie Sau. Und dann musste ich erst mal zurück, weil wir mitten im Wald und wir mussten auch über einen Fluss, weil es gab einen Fluss, aber da lief ein Metallrohr drüber, da war anscheinend eine Wasserleitung oder sowas. und man musste immer über dieses Metallrohr und es war halt ziemlich gefährlich, wenn du darauf läufst, deswegen hat man sich nicht mehr auf dieses Metallrohr drauf gesetzt, wie so auf dem Pferd und hat sich dann so nach vorne gerobbt. Oh mein Gott. Und meine Hände waren halt völlig blutig und dadurch wurde halt dieses ganze Rohr blutig. Ja. Wahrscheinlich bis heute sind dann auch meine Hände, Handspuren drauf von einem achtjährigen Florentin, der seiner Mutter erzählt hat, er ist hingefallen. Er war komplette Körper rot war. Naja, aber du brauchst ja auch... Aber schön, dass bei euch klingt, dass ihr da Flüsse habt und so, wo ihr gespielt habt. Ja, klar. Mir war immer einfach Beton. Nee, aber du brauchst ja auch ein Gewicht bei einer Pfeilspitze. Also damit die Flugeigenschaften gut sind, brauchst du schon ein gewisses Gewicht. Ach so, du meinst, die haben weniger an Safety als an Flugeigenschaften des Pfeils gedacht. Ja, und wenn du auf eine Zielschwelle schiessen willst, willst du ja auch, dass der Pfeil da drin steckt.
Du willst ja nicht, dass dir dagegen prallt oder so und dann weisst du nicht, wo du den geschlossen hast.
Ja, aber dann nimm doch, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, du verstehst, ja.
Ich verstehe die Problematik, aber ich verstehe immer noch nicht, warum man das in einem Toys-Arts verkaufen musste.
Schon weird, einfach eine weird, komische Entscheidung.
Du bekommst ja auch keine echten Pistolen.
Das ist ja nichts anderes, sondern eine Armbrust einfach mit so einem ballistischen Pfeil. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber ich weiß noch, wie ich damals auf Kaltenberg war, auf dem Ritterfestspiel in Kaltenberg bei mir in der Nähe, wo man so eine Burg war und dann waren alle das Ritter verkleidet und das war toll. Und ich war unterwegs mit Stich, mit Bilbos Schwert. Ich hatte eine Replik von Stich, was halt in meiner Welt das coolste, was man haben kann, aus der Sicht dieser Ritter, Reen-Eckman-Leute, halt so das uncoolste, was man haben kann. Ja, du bringst halt so ein Franchise-Fantasy-Kram mit rein. Ja, und die so, das ist hier nicht Mittelerde, okay, wir sind hier Burg Kaltenberg und mit Herzog sowieso und ich halt so mit Fückondo! Das haben die halt gar nicht gern gesehen. Ne, haben die nicht gern gesehen. Aber da konnte man auch... Deine spitzen Ohren haben auch nicht geholfen. Nee, gar nicht. Meines Star Wars-T-Shirt auch nicht, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Und da konnte man Pfeilspitzen kaufen. Und da habe ich ganz viel, weil die sind ja klein und billig, und die waren viel billiger als der ganze Pfeil, und deswegen habe ich da ganz viele Metallpfeilspitzen richtig geschmiedet.
Oh mein Gott.
Und da habe ich ganz viel davon gekauft und mir dann zu Hause eigene Pfeile gemacht, mit dem Holz und dann mit Befiederung und so, aber da habe ich ganz viele Pfeilspitzen gekauft. Also ich hatte auch tödliche Pfeile.
Oh mein Gott, worauf hast du geschossen?
So meine Freunde?
Ganz ehrlich, hast du mal ein Tier umgebracht?
Stefan, komm.
Wie, ich habe eigentlich gehofft, dass jetzt einfach ein Nein kommt, aber... Ich habe mal einen Fisch erschossen. Fisch erschossen? Ja. Einen Fisch erschossen? Ich habe nicht damit gerechnet, dass ich treffe. Man rechnet nicht, weil du denkst, also ich weiß nicht, wie weit ich gedacht habe, aber so, es ist ja auch sehr schwer, Fische zu treffen wegen der Lichtbrechung. Die sind ja nicht da, wo du sie siehst. Der Pfeil ist ja auch automatisch schief, wenn er ins Wasser kommt. Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall kompliziert und ich habe mich selber ein bisschen erschrocken mit der Macht, die ich plötzlich hatte. Ich kann Leben enden. Warum grinst du so doll? Ich kann Leben beenden. Warum grinst du über beide Backen? Wenn ich möchte, hören, Lebewesen aufzuextieren, dann sind dann weg. Und was war das für ein Fisch? Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ist auch egal. Ist auch egal. Aber auf jeden Fall, das war Wahl einfach. No budget. Aber was wir normalerweise gemacht haben, was wir normalerweise gemacht haben, ist, wir haben unser Geld zusammengelegt und haben von Aldi zwei Liter Tetra Pak Eistee gekauft, haben das ins Feld gestellt und darauf geschossen. Weil da bleiben die Pfeile gut drin stecken und da läuft dann Eistee raus, so wie Blut rausläuft. Und das war natürlich das Highlight von so einem Zitronenblut. Leckeres Blut. Und ich weiß noch, wie wir diskutiert haben, ob wir Pfirsich- oder Zitroneneistee kaufen sollen. Warum nicht Kirsch? Und einer meinte so, das war eigentlich egal. Aber ich so, nein, Pfirsicheistee ist besser als Zitroneneistee. Oder einfach, nee, noch besser wäre Kirschsaft. Aber naja, mich hätte ja wieder niemand gefragt. Kirschsaft hat 69 Pfennig gekostet, viel zu teuer. 50 Pfennig trendy Eistee, muss billig sein, wie es geht. Aber ich habe mir letztens noch mal drüber nachgedacht, intensiv, über was für ein Bullshit man sich als Kind gestritten hat, den ganzen Tag, diese Fäden, ständig, was man jetzt natürlich im Internet auch noch so kennt, so, was ist besser, League of Legends oder Dota oder welches, aber damals ja auch so mit Kickboard versus Cityroller war bei uns das große Team. Oh ja, was warst du, Team, ich war Cityroller. Ich war auch Cityroller, ja. Und dann haben wir mal Kackboard gesagt, statt Kickboard. Und da konnten die anderen natürlich mit City-Roller war bei uns das große Team. Oh ja, was warst du, Team? Ich war City-Roller. Ich war auch City-Roller, ja. Und dann haben wir mal Kack-Board gesagt statt Kick-Board. Und da konnten die anderen natürlich mit City-Rollern nicht so viel darauf antworten. Nee, aber die waren ernsthaft getroffen. Und die konnten teilweise ernsthaft nicht schlafen nachts, weil du dann Kack-Roller zu denen gesagt hast. Ja. Ja. Aber das sind Dinge, als Kind hat man so viel Gewicht. Ja, total, vor allem, das ist ja so dieses Thais-Problem, dass wenn du halt mal dein ganzes Taschengeld für rote Schuhe ausgibst, kannst du nicht einfach am nächsten Tag die neue Schuhe kaufen, du musst damit leben. Deswegen gibt es nicht mehr als Sommerferien. Weil das Problem ist ja, das große Problem ist ja, das habe ich aber auch heutzutage noch, dass ich nicht einfach als morgen anderer Mensch sein kann. Ich kann nicht morgen mit einem komplett anderen Klamottenstil in die Firma kommen. Dann würdest du auch sagen, was ist mit dir denn los? Nicht, weil du meinen jetzigen Stil so toll findest, sondern einfach, weil du das nicht akzeptieren würdest. Du akzeptierst ja keine Änderungen. Ich würde es abstoßen. Du würdest aktiv ablehnen, wie die Alpakas, die wir mal angemalt haben, und dann wurden die von ihrer Herde nicht mehr angenommen, was eine traurige Geschichte war, eine wahre Geschichte im Neomagazin. Wir haben damals mit Alpakas gedreht und dann mussten wir die anmalen, einmal in pink und einmal in grün, und dann wurden die nicht mehr angenommen für diese sehr kurze Rubrik, die zwei Sekunden gedauert hat. Die waren wirklich zwei Sekunden. Das Selfie deines Lebens. Ja, aber die wurden wirklich, und Alpakas sind ja krasse Herdentiere, die ja glaube ich auch einfach sterben, wenn sie alleine sind, und die wurden nicht mehr von ihrer Herd angenommen, was einfach zeigt, Alpakas sind rassistisch wie Sau. Ja. Weil es waren ja dieselben Leute, die hatten einfach nur andere. Rassistisch wie Alpakas. Stimmt, ja. Obwohl, eigentlich ist es ja kein Rassismus, es ist ja eigentlich so ein Lookism, würde man vielleicht sagen. Wir sehen ja nur anders aus. Nee, ich wir sind ja auch dudselig. Ich glaube, wir denken immer noch, das sind einfach andere Tiere. Das glaube ich schon. Ich glaube, es ist Fremdenfeindlichkeit. Es ist ja die gleiche Rasse. Ja. Ich weiß es nicht. Das war jedenfalls schlimm und das ist mir auch so aufgekommen, wenn ich das, aber wenn ich morgen komplett pink angezogen wäre, würdest du mich auch nicht einfach so akzeptieren. Und da, aber in der Schule hat man auch den großen Vorteil, dass es Sommerferien gibt. Da kannst du nämlich einen neuen Look, weil, und das ist ja der Punkt, auf den ich hinaus will, es kommt darauf an, wie du etwas trägst. Man akzeptiert es ja eher, wenn derjenige das selbstbewusst trägt und cool damit ist. Aber ich bin ja, das Ding ist, wenn ich neue Sachen anhabe, dann bin ich so self-conscious über diese Sachen, die ich neu anhab, dass mein ganzes Körper sagt, ja, das ist neu.
Ja, du stößt selber ab und dadurch wirst du ab. Und dadurch merken Leute ab, was hast du für Schuhe an, das sind aber süße Schuhchen, ja, die habe ich neu, ziehe ich nicht mehr an. Aber das Gute ist an Sommerferien, da kannst du ja wirklich Looks proben, dich selber an einen einen neuen Look gewöhnen zum Beispiel und so. Und kannst auch vielleicht ein bisschen sparen auf neue Schuhe und so. Du kannst dann aktiv ein neuer Mensch sein nach sechs Wochen Sommerferien. Vor allem nach den Sommerferien sieht ja jeder anders aus. Also gerade in der Pubertät, wo halt einfach jemand als süßer Junge weggeht und zurückkommt und hat halt ein Bart. Einfach Rauchpfeife und hat einen Anzug an. Das ist halt so. Ja, hat einen Blaumann an. Okay, Lukas, hallo. Hi, Dennis. Ich unterrichte jetzt hier. Okay, das ist einfach komplett neuer Mensch. Ich habe jetzt eine Sozialversicherungsnummer. Ich zahle Steuern. Bam, einfach. Boom. Und alle anderen sind noch Pokémon, haben noch Pokémon-Karten. Aber einer, der ist halt schon ein Auto. Ja, genau. Es geht nicht schnell. Es geht nicht schnell. Aber das ist so gut, der kann auch dann zum Beispiel seinen Anzug am ersten Tag zum Beispiel tragen, der ist noch seltsam und kann es dann üben. Er kann es dann lernen zu tragen, bis er sich selber daran wohlfühlt. Und dann kommt er wieder als Anzug, Luca. Ich habe ja meine Haare geschnitten in der Schule, von langer Haare, also wirklich überschulterlang, zu kurz. Und das war echt ein harter Tag. Das ist aber genau auch mitten in der Woche, war ein Dienstag. Ja, bin ich mitten in der Woche, ich weiß noch, erstes schon den Geschichtsunterricht und ich kam zu spät in die erste Stunde. Ja, oh mein Gott. Es gibt ein, die Tür geht nach Unterrichtsbeginn auf, reinkommt, ja, wer ist der Trottel heute, wer ist der Trottel ... Und die ganze Klasse halt so, okay, der hat kurze Haare und du kannst dich ja in der Situation nicht erklären, weil du sagst, Entschuldigung, zu spät kommen, du kannst nicht, ja, Leute, ihr kennt mich ja, ich bin immer noch derselbe, alles kein Problem, ich schulde immer noch. Das ist immer eine Show über dich. Überhaupt kein Problem, jeder kann einmal anfassen und so, sondern du musst es dann einfach wegschweigen. Und dadurch kann dieses Traum auch nicht aufgearbeitet werden, weil man es nicht, weil dieses, hey, du hast eine neue Frisur, ja, ja, habe ich, ja, sieht auch ganz okay aus, ja, und dann ist es auch gut, ist unangenehm, aber gut, aber das konnte nicht aufgearbeitet werden. Grauenhaft. Aber hast du es genossen? Nee. So ein bisschen so eine neue Florian mit einer neuen Frisur, oder war es einfach nur Folter, auch gerade das zu spät kommen? Nee. Ich weiß noch, aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob du das mal erzählt hast, weil ich glaube, das hat mir, glaube ich, rückblickend sehr geholfen, kurze Haare zu haben. Nicht, dass Leute mit langen Haaren weniger wert sind, aber damit ging einem schon ein bisschen ein erster Schritt ins Erwachsenwerden einher. Weil ich sah halt aus wie der letzte Depp. Es ging nicht nur darum, dass ich lange Haare hatte, sondern halt auch diese langen, lockigen Haare, die ungepflegt waren, einfach ... Aber waren die langen Haare denn vorher, war das ein Statement oder eine, du hast dich einer gewissen Nerdigkeit zugehörig gefühlt oder Fantasy-Welt oder war es einfach Paulite? Ich habe Herr der Ringe gesehen und wollte so aussehen wie Aragorn. Wirklich jetzt? Und dazu gehört natürlich, lange Haare zu haben, also für einen Jungen, lange Haare zu haben. Und dann habe ich aber gemerkt, oh, du hast ja lockige Haare, das heißt, deine Haare wachsen nicht nach unten, sondern in einem relativ scharfen 45-Grad-Winkel zur Seite. Und da sah ich erst erstmal aus wie ein Geodreieck. Aber dann hat irgendjemand gesagt, und diese Person verflurig bis heute hat gesagt, nee, nee, wenn die Haare länger werden, dann werden die ja schwerer und dann ziehen die nach unten und dann lösen sich auch die Locken auf, weil das ist wie wenn eine Feder, man die ganz lang zieht, dann ist die ja auch nicht mehr gefedert. Würde ich aber auch denken, dass es richtig ist. Und dann habe ich die einfach weiter wachsen lassen, aber die sind konstant in diesem 45-Grad-Winkel geblieben. Also ich glaube, werden die bis zum Boden weitergewachsen, hätten die so eine ganz präzise, ganz präzise Dreiecksform insgesamt ergeben. Und ab dem Punkt, als du merkst, scheiße, ich werde nicht so aussehen, wie Viggo Mortensen als Aragorn, dann ist es zu spät, weil dann kommst du nicht mehr zurück. Hat der nicht auch leichte Locken? Oder sind das normale Krussel? Die sind immer so ein bisschen nass und fettig, weil der ist ja so Strider-mäßig immer so ein bisschen verschnöselt, der kämmt sich ja nicht und so. Aber war auf jeden Fall furchtbar unab. Dann ist es zu spät. In dem Moment, in dem du merkst, fuck ich sehe bescheuert aus, ist es zu spät. Aber dann hat eine Klassenkameradin, mit der ich ab und zu Kicker gespielt habe. Kicker? Kicker, ja, wir hatten in der Schule einen Kicker. Und dann meinte sie so, und ich glaube, das war sehr, sehr clever von ihr, so, okay, wir machen jetzt so das grosse Kickerturnier, wer ist von uns besser, weil wenn man beide behauptet, wir wären besser im Kicker als
jeweils andere, man ist okay,
und wer gewinnt, wer verliert, muss halt was machen,
wenn du verlierst, musst du dir deine Haare kurz schneiden.
Wo ich rückblickend dachte,
danke dir, weil das
ist das Beste, was man jemandem, der
einen misslungenen Haarschnitt hat und
sich offensichtlich in eine Sackgaste manövriert
hat, sagt, okay, wir machen jetzt eine Wette und wenn du verlierst, dann musst du ab morgen vernünftige Kleidung anziehen, okay, dann musst du abnehmen, okay, wenn du verlierst, musst du 30 Kilo abnehmen. Aber so als Challenge, als lustiges Spiel verpacken, das ist halt clever von ihr, war das, ja, mega. Wie sah sie aus, war sie normal? Ja, ja, sie meinte, sie färbt sich ihre Haare lila dann, wenn sie verliert. Ah, okay. Was sie vielleicht eh vorhat. Also sie hatte schon clever eingefädelt. Clever. Und ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich gar nicht mehr, wie es am Ende ausging. Ich weiß nur, dass wir beide unseren Wetteinsatz gemacht haben. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das abgelaufen ist. Auf jeden Fall beide, sie hat lila gefärbt. Ich hatte ... Ich habe mir das zugewaren, mach das lieber trotzdem. Ich habe zwar die letzten zwei Wochen intensiv Kicker trainiert, aber habe trotzdem verloren. Aber lass es trotzdem machen. Dann habe ich es trotzdem gemacht. Aber tatsächlich ideale Möglichkeit, jemandem mit seinem, der offensichtlich festgefahren ist, in dem Look zu helfen. So, aber jetzt ist natürlich, kommt es natürlich aus der Welt des, ich lasse meine Haare
den natürlichen
Weg gehen, hin zu
jetzt will ich eine Frisur. So, jetzt ist
Kurzhaar ja nicht Kurzhaar. Das spreche
ich aus eigener Erfahrung. Sie will ja nur Kurzhaar
hat, immer. So, das ist ja
auch eine Entscheidung, wie kurz, was
für eine Frisur, willst du den
Undercut, willst du den
den Zickenübergang haben, wie es so langsam blendet in Richtung Bart, wie willst du das haben? Und was war dann deine Entscheidung, was war dein Satz beim Friseur? Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage, weil die Frage ist ja, ich hatte die Möglichkeit, mich komplett neu zu erfinden. Genau, Stufenschnitt, wie so krasse Koteletten. Nee, aber ich habe dann tatsächlich ein altes Kinderfoto von mir rausgesucht, wo ich noch keine langen Haare hatte. Irgendwie wirklich, da war ich dann wirklich richtig jung und bin mit dem Foto, mit dem entwickelten Foto, also wirklich einem haptischen Foto, dem einzigen Unikat. Ein Foto? Foto, bin ich zum Friseur gegangen, bin ich zum Friseur gegangen und habe gesagt, so will ich gerne aussehen. Und da war halt so ein süsser, lächelnder achtjähriger Junge drauf. Und die wussten nicht mehr, dass du warst. Die dachten einfach, du zeigst ein Foto von einem achtjährigen und denken so, what a day. So will ich gerne aussehen. Kommt so ein grosser, langhaariges Geodreieck in den Reihen gewackelt. Ja. Okay, und dann haben die das ... Und dann wurde mir die Haare geschnitten und dann sah ich auch wieder acht Jahre aus. Aber ja, ab dann hatte ich eigentlich durchgehend kürzere Haare. Aber das ist, glaube ich, gut. Ich glaube, so wurden Wetten auch erfunden einfach. Ich bin immer kein Freund von so Challenges und da muss man was Ekliges essen. Das finde ich immer doof. Das schaue ich mir auch nie gerne an im Fernsehen irgendwie, irgendwie der Verlierer muss jetzt dann irgendwie irgendwas machen, das finde ich immer uninteressant, aber ich glaube, so wurde das ursprünglich erfunden, dass man einfach sagt, jemandem so einen Push zu geben, als Korrektiv, als Korrektiv, ja, als soziales Korrektiv, die Wette als soziales Korrektiv. Genau, weil zu unnötig ist, einfach zu sagen, hör mal, dieser Haare, es geht gar nicht, es stinkt, sieht aus wie ein Geodreieck, lass es. Nie, lass es mal gucken, wer diesen Stein hier weiterwerfen kann. Und wenn du verlierst, machst du mit deiner Freundin Schluss, okay? Einfach als Scheiss, oder? Genau, und wenn ich gewinne, dann darf ich mit der Freundin, darf ich dann zum Beispiel mal abends weggehen oder sowas. Okay. Deal, deal, verdammt. Ja, das kann gut sein, ich finde, ich kenne keinen schlechten Impuls. Okay, und seitdem bist du der Florentin, das ist so. Seitdem bin ich der Florentin, den man kennt. Den man halt so kennt, den man sich vorstellt. Aber hast du dann auch diesen krassen Move, diese körperliche Veränderung, genutzt, um anders zu sein? Also hast du dir vorgenommen, dein selbstbewusster, cooler zu sein? Ich glaube schon, dass ich dadurch selbstbewusster wurde, aber ich habe es mir nicht direkt vorgenommen. Aber ich glaube, worauf ich auch Bock hätte mal, ist so ein Koma. Weil ich glaube, wenn du aus einem Koma aufwachst, kannst du dich wirklich von Grund auf neu erfinden. Und wirklich so einfach neu anfangen, weil niemand wird, weil jeder sagt, seid ihr aus einem Koma auf, also jeder hat Verständnis dafür, weil niemand ein Koma, wenn du machst ein Koma und dann kleidest du dich anders.
Du kannst dich auch verhalten wie das grösste Arschloch, ich glaube, Leute werden immer noch nett, weil die denken, oh, Koma. Zum Beispiel so Dinge wie die Stimme. Es gibt ja vielleicht Leute, die mögen nicht, wie sie reden.
Die würden vielleicht lieber so reden, den ganzen Tag. Vielleicht. Ich finde, das klingt viel schöner, aber ich kann jetzt nicht einfach von einem Tag auf den anderen anfangen, so zu reden. Nein, das kannst du nicht. Aber es sei denn, du fällst in den Koma und dann, wenn du aus dem Koma aufwächst, oh, hallo. Oder sechs Wochen Sommerferien. Wie gesagt, einfach ein bisschen ändern. Du kannst es ja proben.
Herr Dietze, wir haben Ihnen vor zehn Jahren hatten Sie einen Stimmbruch. Da gab es leider ein kleines Problem, den bräuchten wir leider zurück, wenn es geht. Da haben wir leider noch mal, da haben wir einen kleinen Fehler. Okay, gut. Und dann einfach so. Aber das einfach mal für Neuerfinden. Ich finde auch, ja. Gut, Stimme ist ein spannendes Thema. Ich glaube, die meisten sprechen auch gar nicht so, wie sie eigentlich sprechen würden. Das habe ich mal gelernt beim Stimmtraining, damals in der Uni habe ich ja auch immer hier erzählt, aber dass die Tonlage, in der man spricht, häufig durch soziale Umstände beeinflusst wird und so. Und die wenigsten haben die Stimme da sitzen, wo sie bei einem auch wirklich sitzt. Manche stehen auch. Manche stehen auch. Ein Beispiel von der Sprachträne damals waren Homosexuelle teilweise, die höher sprechen, war das gesellschaftlich so, keine Ahnung, habe ich nicht genau verstanden, also ob das jetzt, woher das jetzt dann kommt also ob die dann eher weiss nicht die weiblichkeit denn auch weil er offensichtlich nach vorne tragen wollen oder ob so eine gesellschaft dann ja weiss nicht genau habe ich nicht ganz verstanden aber was ich zumindest nachvollziehen kann ist dass frauen zum beispiel teilweise dann vielleicht die in krassen führungspositionen sind ja vielleicht dann eher eher sich gegen Männer durchsetzen wollen, vielleicht dann höher sprechen oder so, weil sie die Stimme dann besser durchsetzt. Keine Ahnung, aber ich glaube schon, dass sich manchmal hier und da einfach die Stimme so ein bisschen anpasst, je nach Umständen und so. Und es wird häufig als unangenehm empfunden. Und Ziel des Sprechtrainings war dann auch, mit so einem weirden Gummischlauch im Mund und dem richtigen Luftdruck herauszufinden, wo denn die Stimme eigentlich sitzt oder steht.
Also was deine authentische Stimme ist.
Und hat sich da viel verändert?
Bei mir nicht, weil ich ja auch davor schon Gesangsunterricht hatte und mit dem Podcast viel gesprochen habe und so, da ging das eigentlich.
Da habe ich ein Kompliment bekommen von der, aber bei den anderen ging sehr viel ab auf jeden Fall. Teilweise hat sich da richtig viel getan, das ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Übung gewesen. Ich muss mal herausfinden, was das für eine Übung war. Er hat auf jeden Fall einen aus dem Baumarkt gekauften Plastikschlauch beinhaltet. Aber auf der anderen Seite vielleicht auch so eine andere Art zu sprechen, weil
zum Beispiel, man merkt es ja immer sehr, wenn Leute
imitiert werden, so
Stimmenimitationen, dann arbeiten die ja
und übertreiben ja auch oft einzelne
Merkmale von der Stimme, irgendwie so,
halt irgendwie Owen Wilson, so wow, wow,
so, halt so.
Wow. Ja, oder halt so ein Wort,
das man immer wieder sagt,
I'm Donald J. Trump.
Verdammt noch mal, als würde
er vor mir stehen, als würde
Er Ja, oder halt so ein Wort, das man immer wieder sagt. I'm Donald J. Trump. Verdammt nochmal, als würde er vor mir stehen. Als würde er vor mir stehen. Ich konnte sehr gut nachmachen, aber jetzt nicht mehr. Dieses Stimmtraining hat mir den abtrainiert. Ich konnte sehr gut Kevin Spacey in House of Cards nachmachen. Ja? Sehr, sehr gut. Wenn du mir jetzt einen englischen Text vorlesen könntest, könnte ich das, glaube ich, ganz gut nachmachen. Aber das ist der einzige, weil, ich weiß nicht, kriege ich das, das Homme, Homme, kriege ich hin. Hwatt, mit diesem Hwatt, Hwatt, Hwatt. Naja, das, aber das sonst stimmt, das, manche können das sehr gut hinkriegen, auch, je nachdem, wie sie den Kehlkopf stellen, den Mund aufmachen können, das erinnert ja auch viel. Ja, aber da ist ja die Frage, wie würde jemand sich selbst imitieren, also wie würde ein Stimmitator mich imitieren, was würde der herausarbeiten, welche Charakteristika? Charakteristika, wie würde der mich, naja. Versuchen wir mal mich zu imitieren. Ja, so so also du hast natürlich schon du hast eine ein bisschen höhere Stimme als ich glaube ich, weiss ich aber auch nicht ehrlich gesagt du bist schon sehr bei dir aber du hast ein bisschen so ein offeneres offeneres Sprech und ein bisschen nasaler noch okay was mir echt aufgefallen ist nee hast mich nicht mehr, aber je mehr du abgenommen hast in dem Podcast, desto weniger nasal klingst du. Du klingst ganz anders. Nee, ich finde es eigentlich gar nicht komisch. Aber da habe ich auch drüber nachgedacht, weil was, also ich meine, man nimmt ja an Stellen, an Volumen zu, wo Fettablagerungen sind. Aber wo, ist es ja noch nirgendwo im Mund oder so Fett? Oder sind es allein die Wangen oder was? Nee, aber Fett ist ja auch, glaube ich, teilweise zwischen den Organen. Es gibt ja inneres Fett und äusseres Fett und so.
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass gerade dein Gesicht und der Rachen- und Mundtrakt, der hängt ja schon so ein bisschen, da ist ja ein Limit irgendwann durch Knochen und so, so ein Knorpel.
Und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wenn da so tiefere Fettschichten immer grösser werden, dass da schon was zuschwillt. Wie, man wird von innen fetter oder was? Auch, ja. Überall. Alles wird fetter, Blut wird dicker. Ich dachte, Fett ist so eine Wärmeschutzschicht von außen. Nee, auch zwischen Organen. Wurde ich das auch immer nicht check, weil die Haut, man fühlt sich ja warm und kalt mit der Haut und die Haut ist ja über dem Fett. Also wie kann das Fett einen warm halten? Ich verstehe schon, dass die inneren Organe dann Wärme sind, aber checkt die Haut dann, dass sie weniger kaltes Feedback senden muss, weil sie ja mehr Fett drunter hat? Oder wie geht das? Keine Ahnung, wo sind denn Nerven? Die Nervenenden sind schon ganz vorne an der Haut, oder? Nee, weiß ich nicht. Gibt ja auch Hautschichten. Ich weiß es nicht. Du meinst so aus der letzten Reihe, so die unterste Hautschicht hat dann auch noch was zu geben. Und die oben sind mega nervös die ganze Zeit, super kalt, super kalt. Und hinten, von unten ruft dann so eine Hautschicht so, nö, ist doch voll okay. Nö, mir ist nicht kalt. So acht Meter fett zwischen uns. Ich weiß es echt nicht, keine Ahnung. Selbst die Haut schickt ja auch noch mal kleine Härchen vor. Und ist ja noch nicht mal die letzte Instan. Alle schicken was vor, ne? Ja. Und auch die Herrchen sind ja auch einfach nur noch irgendwann so Horn. Die weichen ja aus, wenn dann Luft kommt. Ja, alle haben keinen Bock auf Luft. Und dann so wie die zappeln, merkt dann die Haut, oh, das Haar zappelt. Und dann steht das erstmal auf, Gänsehaut mässig. Ja. Viele Schutzmechanismen, die dann erstmal kommen, bevor die Kälte an den Körper rein kann.
Wir werden wahrscheinlich viele Mails bekommen, genau wie ich letzte Woche ganz viele Mails bekommen habe zum Thema YouTube-Downloader. Mir wurde sehr oft empfohlen der J-Downloader, den ich jetzt auch ausprobiert habe, der mir auch gut gefällt. Leider hat jedes, ich habe das Gefühl, die Welt der YouTube-Downloader ist wie so ein großes Puzzle. Und jedem Downloader fehlt ein Feature, das ein anderer Downloader aber hat, aber der hat dafür ein anderes Feature nicht. Der eine kann HD-Downloaden, dafür benennte die Dateien nicht richtig, der andere kann ... Oh, das ist ja nicht schlimm. Das finde ich kein Schlimmes. Aber was ganz schlimm ist, ist wenn die, was ich auch nicht ganz checke, aber da geht es jetzt zu, ich bin da sehr tief drin, was bestimmt, wann, bei Einheit steht ja zuletzt geändert am, was genau bestimmt ist, weil es reicht nicht, wenn man den Titel der Datei ändert, das ändert es nicht, und manchmal lädt man eine Datei runter und die hat zuletzt geändert 2008 oder so, das ist aber auch nicht das Upload-Datum. Oh, das ist spannend. Das ist ganz strange. Ja, das ist manchmal sehr interessant. Und da würde ich ja gerne offensichtlich setz dich doch bitte auf den Moment, wo ich es da umgedacht habe. Das ist auch blöd, weil dann sind die in der Liste ganz weit unten, die du gerade runtergeladen hast und andere sind oben, ist alles konfus, aber dafür HD. Aber ich fahre ganz gut mit dem J-Downloader und ich habe viele Tipps bekommen. Es scheint ein Thema zu sein, das viele Leute interessiert. Wir rufen ja auf Spenden für Afrika, Heuschreckenplage, kurz vor Uganda ist kurz dabei, die gesamte Ostafrika aufzufressen. Kein einziger Cent kommt an. Und wenn man einmal fragt nach dem YouTube-Downloader, schon strömen die Mails hier rein und wir können kaum noch atmen hier vor Post. Ja, und dann haben wir eine Nachricht bekommen. Von Schmiede? Nee, von jemandem, der mit Schmiede zusammen studiert hat. Warum kriegst du diese Nachrichten? Ich glaube, die haben wir beide bekommen. Lass mich mal kurz diese Nachricht finden. Alter, Schmiede? Obwohl Leute auch gesagt haben, man muss Clip Grab oder Clip Crab, wie ich es mittlerweile nenne, muss es auch nur updaten, dann geht es wieder. Aber die Erfahrung habe ich nicht gemacht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich will Beef mit Philipp Schmiede haben, der Entwickler von Clip Crab. Ich sage jetzt nicht, von wem die Nachricht kommt, weil sie gemein wird, um ehrlich zu sein. Aber ey, no shit, Philipp Schmiede hat bei mir studiert und ist ein unglaublicher Langweiler. Nein, stopp, hier wird nicht der Name von Philipp Schmiede in den Dreck gezogen. Es geht auch weiter. Und ein ganz, ganz merkwürdiger Typ gewesen. Allerdings sprach er schon 2010 davon, dass er eine tolle Seite programmiert hat, nur hat ihn niemand von uns ernst genommen. Wie geil! So eine Mark Zuckerberg-Geschichte, aber am Ende hast du so einen Download. Also halt nur Clip-Grab. Ist halt so, also, aber ich verstehe auch, es ist wahrscheinlich trotzdem doch krass. Ernst genommen. Eines Tages werde ich ein Programm schreiben, mit dem man Videos aus dem Internet runterladen kann. Schaut euch den Schmiede an, der denkt, er könnte ein Programm schreiben, mit dem man Videos runterladen kann. Na, ihr werdet es schon sehen. Na dann, programmier mal, Schmiede. Von den Machern von The Social Network. Aaron Zorkins, neuer Mega-Blockbuster. Der Typ, der Clip-Grabber von... Um eine Million Gigabyte runterzuladen. Warum nimmt niemand ernst? Das ist kein krasses Vor... Er hat sich nicht das krasseste vorgenommen.
Er wollte halt einen YouTube-Downloader.
Aber alle haben ihn ausgeladen. Heim im Informatikstudium.
Eines Tages werde ich eine Seite programmieren,
die YouTube-Videos in einer schlechteren
Qualität runterladen kann,
die sie schlecht benannt. Aber er kann es
runterladen. Bruno, guck mal, ich habe hier einen Link geschickt
bekommen. Clipgrab.de. Wow. Ist er da draufklicken? Was glaubst du, du kannst das? Keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich wieder irgendeine Fake-Seite von diesem... Moment mal. Mal kurz. Download-Videos? Warte mal, ich gebe mal irgendeinen Link ein. Ja, kurz einen YouTube-Link hier, Nyan Cat, bitte. Okay. Was? Ein Prozent, zwei Prozent.
Ja, gut.
Der lädt das runter.
Das ist locker ein Virus oder so ein Scheiß.
Das kann nicht sein.
Du kennst doch Schmidi.
Wer weiß schon davon.
Du kennst doch Schmidi, das ist der fucking Nerd.
99, 100, hier.
Das, what?
Alter, der hat es wirklich geschafft.
Weißt du was?
Wir programmieren diese Seite. Wir klauen den Code. Ich heiss Jay und du heisst Downloader. Und du heisst Downloader. Ich weiss, wie du heisst. Das musst du mir jetzt nicht sagen. Und zusammen heisst unsere Seite Jay Downloader. Aber hier kommt unser Twist. Unsere Seite benennt die Dateien, wie das Video heißt. Und das Datum ist kompletter Bullshit. Das ist egal. Bei jedem Clip. Random. Ja, das ist geil. Random Clip. Random Datum. Und unsere Schülerband, die Videos von unserer Schülerband aus dem Kanal, die dürfen nicht gedownouten werden.
Nee, die nicht. Oder die kriegt jeder automatisch dazu, wenn ein Video...
Das U2-Album aufbaut.
Wie so ein kostenloses Probebeispiel.
Eine Goodie-Band.
Möchten Sie zehn Sekunden von diesem Video? Nee, eigentlich nicht. Ja, hier trotzdem.
Aber wir spielen nächste Woche in The Clam.
Alter, ja, ich glaube, dann haben wir keine Chance, Schmiede zu finden, wenn der
sich gegen solche Erwartungen
durchsetzt. Das ist schon krass.
Aber was ist ein weder
Informatikkurs, dass sie ihn ernst genommen
haben? Er hätte jetzt nicht
gesagt, ich will die Weltvereinigung Präsident werden.
Er wollte einen fucking Clip
für Stoneloader.
Vielleicht ist es aber auch ein ganz spezieller Informatikkurs,
wo jemand sagt, Leute, ich spiele später nochmal in die Bib, ne? Ob du wirklich später in die Bib gehst? Ich glaube nicht. Ein sehr fauler Kurs offensichtlich. Was ist das für ein Kurs? Ich nehme kurz was zu essen, wenn wir tanke nebenan. Ja, hol dir auch was zu essen. Viel Glück. Okay Das ist ein überskeptischer Kurs. Das ist ein Zufall. Die ganzen skeptischen Menschen der Uni, einfach alle in diesem einen Seminar aus irgendeinem Grund. So hören wir auf und dann machen wir morgen einfach weiter bei Datenbanken. Machen wir morgen weiter? Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass wir morgen... Genau, morgen um zehn Uhr dann einfach weiter im selben Raum.
Ha! Zehn!
Ihr werdet schon sehen, wenn ich morgen hier auftauche.
Und dann machen wir Datenbanken!
Oh mein Gott, sehr lustig aber.
Jeder Tag einfach ein Drama.
Und ich möchte nicht zu viel verraten noch über diese Person, die es geschrieben hat, aber die hat einen blauen Haken. Mehr möchte ich nicht sagen. Oh, jetzt muss ich es mir zeigen. Aber ist es jemand, den man kennt? Nein! Ich weiß nicht, wer das ist. Alter, das ist das Holy Crap, das ist das grösste Drama, das grösste Drama, die grösste Story 2020. Für dich jetzt? Ich weiß nicht, wer das ist. Alter, okay, das wird ein Ding. Das wird noch ein Ding, ja. Kennst du den, der es geschickt hat? Oder die? Ich sag dir nichts weiter. Ich will mich da nicht einmischen. Ich will hier nicht zwischen Schmiede und seine Hater. Auf gar keinen Fall. Aber das heißt, du kennst über mehrere Ecken zumindest mal den oder die, die das geschickt haben.
Ich glaube, es ist unkleber darüber zu sprechen.
Wir kommen nicht weiter.
Kommen wir zu wirklich wichtigen Themen.
Ein riesiger Heustreckenschwarm sucht Ostafrika heim.
Oh.
Aber wo ist Ostafrika eigentlich genau? Im Westen von Afrika. Ja, leider war eine falsch rum. Wann hört Ost, das haben wir schon oft gefragt, wann hört Ostafrika eigentlich auf? Oder Südafrika? Wie tief muss man in das Land vordringen, damit Südafrika nicht mehr Südafrika ist? Ja, und wo ist Mittelafrika? Und dann gibt es noch Niederbayern und Oberbayern. Ja, Oberfranken. Das ist ganz merkwürdig. Aber diese und viele weitere Fragen haben wir natürlich großes Interesse daran, die zu klären in unserer ganz fantastischen Rubrik. Sehr beliebt ist auch, wir kriegen sehr viele, sehr guten Zuspruch für diese Rubrik. Ihr könnt es bestimmt schon ahnen und freut euch bestimmt schon hier, meine Damen und Herren, ist Antenne Afrika.
Afrika ist ein wunderschöner Kontinent, über den man so wenig weiß. Man weiß nichts darüber. Vor allem wir Elfenbeinturmeuropäer westlichen Kulturen. Wo kommt das Elfenbein eigentlich her? Ja, das stimmt, das wäre das beste Beispiel gewesen.
Und nicht nur ist Afrika kein Land, sondern sogar 55 Länder, die sich zusammengetan haben und gesagt haben, wir wollen jetzt hier zusammen Afrika sein.
Nee.
Doch.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass sie zusammen Afrika sein wollen. Die haben das Glück oder Pech, je nachdem wie gut sie sich verstehen, einen Kontinent zu bilden.
Aber es gab doch bestimmt schon mal Beschreibungen zu United States of Africa, oder? Das weiß ich nicht. Wir sind die USA jetzt. Und natürlich sind diese 55 Länder sehr unterschiedlich und jedes für sich natürlich eine Reise und eine zumindest mentale Reise wert. Und wir haben schon einige Länder entdeckt in unserer fantastischen Rubrik Antenne Afrika, denn es gibt tatsächlich mehr Menschen in Afrika,
als man denkt. Mehr Leute, die unseren
Podcast auch hören, als man denkt.
Was für uns ganz toll ist, weil wir ganz tolle Beiträge bekommen.
Und heute haben wir einen ganz tollen Beitrag
aus dem wundervollen Land Sambia.
Jetzt kannst du ja ganz kurz schon mal
vorwegnehmen, was weißt du denn jetzt
vor diesem Beitrag alles schon über Sambia?
Es reimt sich auf,
ich glaube es ist Nachbarland,
Gambia.
Das ist so wie die Zwerge bei
Herr der Ringe, wo du so Oin, Gläu,
Odi, Bodin und so hast du auch Sambia, Gambia,
Uganda, Ruanda, immer so Paare.
Vielleicht waren die auch mal zusammen und haben sich dann
getrennt. Das kann gut sein.
Bei der Name fand er aber cool und haben sich ja von Anfangsbuchstaben einig.
Ja, ich weiß gar nichts über Sambia, nichts und ich bin auch sehr froh, jetzt eine Menge darüber zu erfahren.
Das wird sich gleich ändern, denn hier kommt der Beitrag über Sambia von Tabo. Ganz viel Spaß.
So würde euch mein Kumpel Nathan in Sambia in Empfang nehmen. Die Sprache, die ihr eben gehört habt, ist übrigens Nyanja, eine der 42 in Sambia gesprochenen Stammessprachen. Die offizielle Amtssprache des Landes ist jedoch Englisch. Nyanja wird vor allem in der Hauptstadt Lusaka gesprochen, in der ich auch sieben Monate gelebt habe. Das Land befindet sich im südlichen Teil des
Kontinents Afrika. Umgeben ist Sambia von den Ländern Tansania, Malawi, Mosambik,
Zimbabwe, Botswana, Namibia, Angola und der Demokratischen Republik Kongo. Im Süden Sambias
befindet sich die Stadt Livingston mit den wirklich beeindruckenden Viktoria-Fällen. Diese
stellen gleichzeitig den Grenzübergang zu Zimbabwe dar. Ein echtes Highlight Sambias ist auch der
Das war es. sich die Stadt Livingston mit den wirklich beeindruckenden Victoria-Fällen. Diese stellen gleichzeitig den Grenzübergang zu Simbabwe dar. Ein echtes Highlight-Sambias ist auch der Zambezi mit seiner überwältigenden Flora und Fauna. Die Zambier sind unheimlich gastfreundlich.
Bei jeder Gelegenheit, ob im Supermarkt, auf der Strasse oder mitten auf dem Zambezi, ergeben
sich spannende und inspirierende Gespräche. In Anbetracht der Weihnachtszeit folgt jetzt noch ein kleines Ständchen meines lieben Freundes Shepard, der gerade zehn Jahre alt geworden ist. E-i-i-ch-a-me-di-christ-ma-s-a-b-i-n-o-j-a-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-d Da es sich wirklich nur um einen kleinen Überblick handeln soll, sage ich jetzt Sikomo, Dankeschön für euren tollen Podcast und Muli Bwangi macht es gut.
Sikomo, Muli Bwangi auch zurück an Tabor und Happy New Year, Stefan.
Ja, ist eine Zeitverschiebung, hat jetzt ein bisschen reingekickt. In Sambia lernen wir also, jetzt ist noch Weihnachten. Genau, wir vereinen das ganze Jahr Weihnachten. Vielen, vielen Dank aus Sambia. Wir haben wieder ein weiteres Land gelernt. Viktoria-Fälle klingt wirklich nach einer Reise wert. Ja, klingt toll. Die große Wasserfälle ist auf jeden Fall ein Naturspektakel, das mich anzieht, weil Wasserfälle sind immer gut zu bereisen, weil du bist halt unten im Boot, guckst dir das an und dann ist cool, du musst nicht irgendwo raufsteigen, so, du kannst ja einfach unten selber angucken. Und es ist laut. Das ist wie ein faulen Reiser. Nee, aber ernsthaft, wenn du Reiseziele wähle, ich bringe mir nach Lautstärke aus. Je lauter eine Reiseziele, desto besser, weil du nicht so ein, oh,, oh schön, wollen wir wieder gehen, sondern cool, was ist schön hier, was, was, die Bälle sind schön, so schön und dann geht man wieder heim, es ist einfach fantastisch. Ja, wir haben schon einige Menge von Ländern gelernt. Stefan, wollen wir ganz kurz mal zusammenfassen, welche Länder wir alle schon gelernt haben in Antenne Afrika? Also, ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich habe viel gelernt über Namibia. Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich merke mir Namibia und Uganda. Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas, müssen wir es immer dabei sagen eigentlich, und ich nehme mit Namibia, Uganda und Tansania. Ich lerne die in Afrikas und ich merke mir Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Ruanda. Genau, ich lerne die Lände Afrikas und nehme mit Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Ruanda und Äthiopien. Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich merke mir Uganda, Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Ruanda, Äthiopien und Sambia.
Gott sei Dank. Das war unsere tolle Rubrik Antenne Afrika. Nass, Gonya, wie es überwacht,
wie es überwacht,
wie es überwacht, wie es überwacht, wie es überwacht, wie es überwacht, wie es über. Und falls ihr denkt, Afrika ist so ein sympathischer Kontinent, dann spendet gerne, denn es ist tatsächlich so, dass sie gerade unter einem Heustreckenschwarm einfach zusammenbrechen. Echt jetzt? Ja, es ist wirklich so, Ostafrika, riesiger Heuschrecken-Schwarm. Einfach no bullshit. Irgendwie, ich glaube, 17 Millionen Menschen verlieren ihr Essen, weil es weggefressen wurde von den Heuschrecken.
Finde ich mega gut, dass du das machst. Ich finde es weird, dass du jetzt meine Anmoderation mit dem Podcast-Preis so untergraben hast und nicht einfach wie so ein Arschloch. Ich wusste jetzt, dass du doch immer beim Afrika-Thema bist. Das kannst du doch vor dem Jingle machen.
Stefan.
Aber jetzt hast du mich so ins offene Messer laufen lassen, in offenen Speer. Ich wusste jetzt, dass du doch immer beim Afrika-Thema bist. Das kannst du aber vor dem Jingle machen.
Aber jetzt hast du mich so ins offene Messer laufen lassen, ins offenen Speer laufen lassen, dafür, dass ich jetzt anfange, für uns Werbung zu machen.
Dann sagst du, ach übrigens, spende noch für Afrika.
Wohltätigkeit wurde nur dafür erfunden, um andere Leute wie selbstsüchtige, egoistische Arschlöcher dastehen zu lassen. Und es funktioniert. Es funktioniert einfach. Ich selber hasse mich jetzt ein bisschen mehr.
Ja, ist doch gut.
Ja, ist doch gut. So, das war eine tödliche Stimme.
So, ich habe
ein Problem
gelöst, eine Frage geklärt, die
uns alle beschäftigt, seit Folge
zwei, glaube ich, oder drei.
Das Kleingeld, was wir
zu Hause haben, ist immer ein grosses Thema
gewesen. Wir hatten Umschläge, wir hatten Eimer, ich habe mittlerweile Schüsseln voll gehabt. So, jetzt ziehe ich um. Und was habe ich gemacht? Ich habe mein ganzes Kleingeld genommen und es zur Bank gebracht. Richtig, mein ganzes Kleingeld habe ich genommen, ich habe mich aufgerafft und habe es ab Säckeweise zur Bank gebracht.
Ich hatte so eine große Schüssel, die habe ich dann wiederum, damit es nicht in meinem Rucksack alles umkippt und ich dann da stehe und die Pennies aus meinem Rucksack krame, habe das Ganze noch in eine Mülltüte gepackt, in den Rucksack und ab zur Bank, ab dafür, war bei der Bank und dann kannst du es theoretisch, irgendwo gibt es einen Platz in Köln, dann kann man das da hinbringen und dann kann man das irgendwo reinkippen und so und dann kann man es dann kostenlos machen. Ich wollte einfach zur Sparkasse gehen, dachte, das geht ja auch. Nein, geht nicht. Da muss man dann das in so einen Beutel umfüllen und bezahlt dann 7,50 Euro tatsächlich. Bezahlt man schon um diesen Beutel, damit die das zur Zentralbank schicken und so weiter und dann kriegt man es aufs Konto irgendwann gutgeschrieben. So, ich hatte also eine Menge Kleingeld wirklich und ich wusste nicht genau, wie viel das dann gibt. Und ich habe kein Gefühl dafür gehabt, ich bin auch sehr schlecht im Schätzen. Aber es war so eine grosse Metallschüssel, sie war richtig, sie war schon gross, so im Schnitt so vielleicht eher keine 30 Zentimeter. Nur gut, wenn du sagst, ich bin echt schlecht im Schätzen dann eher so ungefähr 30 cm gross, okay jetzt muss man eben abziehen wie schätzt man das jetzt ein, deine Information es war schlecht, also es ist entweder deutlich mehr oder weniger genau und es waren am Ende 194 Euro Das ist ja nix.
Geht so.
Na, Stefan.
Ich fand das sehr viel. Für Kleingeldfreunde ist das ein Anfänger.
Ist das ein gutes Wochenende.
194 Euro.
Fand ich supergut.
Aus dem Nichts.
Hab ich jetzt.
Also nicht aus dem Nichts.
Aber es war dir ein bisschen zu wenig und dann hast du es zu deiner Wie einfach in Müll geworfen.
Ja. Ein Kumpel von mir hat es beim Umzug gemacht. Kleingeld weggeworfen? Einfach Kleingeld weggeworfen. Einfach in Gulli? Nee, in Müll. Weird. Aber natürlich versteht man den Impuls, dem würde man nicht nachgehen, ich nicht zumindest. Aber also Kleingeld ist einfach dusselig, sollte man einfach abschaffen. Ja, mir haben auch viele Leute einen Artikel geschickt und zwar heißt es, weil so viele Leute Kleingeld bunkern, naja, es gibt zwei Informationen. Erstens, viele Leute bunkern Kleingeld, zweitens, es gibt Überlegungen, ob man nicht die ein oder zwei Cent Münze abschaffen will. Das wurde mir so verkauft, dass das zusammenhängt, aber ich verstehe es nicht ganz, wenn man sie abschafft, warum also die Leute bunkern ja nicht nur ein oder zwei Cent Münze, egal, wir nehmen es jetzt einfach mal zwei getrennte Informationen hin und kein drüber, Holland macht das jetzt, glaube ich, und Norwegen und so ein paar fortschrittliche Länder als Deutschland halt. Und da sind sehr teure, teuer herzustellende Produkte. Und man kann einfach auch auf und abrunden. Das ist ja kein Ding, das ist ja kein Step. Ja, aber dann hast du halt wieder diesen Superman-3-Effekt von Office Space. Was? Ich habe nicht kein Wort verstanden, von dem hast du gerade gesagt hast. Superman 3-Effekt von Office Space. Ich habe acht Fragen. Der Film Office Space. Da wird thematisiert, eine Art zu betrügen. Und zwar ist es anscheinend bei grossen Banken oder generell Firmen, die viel mit Geld zu tun haben, müssen manchmal Centbeträge auf- oder abgerundet werden. Es kann ja nicht 0,5 Cent sein. Oder irgendwas 0,5 Cent, dann müssen die auf- und abgerundet werden und dann hat irgendein Betrügung, ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich passiert, hat irgendjemand diese Auf- und Abrundemechanik ausgenutzt und hat immer abgerundet, aber dann 0,5 Cent an ihn überwiesen oder an irgendwo anders überwiesen und irgendwie diese Rundung, die niemandem aufgefallen ist, war ja immer so 0,3 Cent fällt hier immer über den Tisch und es prüft niemand nach, was mit denen passiert, in Anführungszeichen. Und der hat das sich alles überweisen lassen oder irgendwie gesammelt, keine Ahnung, und hatte dann irgendwie Millionen Euro in so einer Bank, die hat jeden Tag mit zigtausenden Transaktionen agiert und hat dadurch ganz viel Geld bekommen. Und irgendwann kam das raus, dass diese ganzen abgerundeten Beträge irgendwo zusammenlaufen. Und das ist voll okay. Findest du okay? Finde ich voll okay. Und das, und ja, Superman 3 ist für dich völlig in Ordnung, oder was? Ich verstehe immer noch nicht genau, wo das jetzt herkommt. Das weiß ich auch nicht genau. Aber Superman 3 klingt für mich okay. Wenn es niemandem aufgefallen ist, ein Diebstahl ist für dich okay sagen Sie niemandem auf, ey. Nein. Solange es niemand rauskriegt, ärgert es sich ja niemand. Die Hälfte soll er wieder abgeben. Die Hälfte wäre ja aufgerundet worden. Das heißt, die soll er wieder abgeben, aber die Hälfte, die eh abgerundet worden wäre, die kann er ja nehmen. Völlig okay. Recherchiert das mal lieber zu Hause selber noch mal nach, wie das am Knochen ist. Aber ich glaube, irgendwas ist da passiert. Generell, gute Idee bei unserem Podcast. Einfach nicht mal, nicht uns für voll nehmen, sondern erstmal nochmal zu Hause mal recherchieren. Aber wo geht das Geld hin? Also ich kaufe uns die Zitrone für 63 Cent und dann sagt der Kassierer, machen wir 60 draus. Oder wie? Genau, die Regel ist dann, ab sechs wird aufgerundet, bis fünf wird abgerundet. Das ist die Regel, ändert sich ja im Schnitt nicht. Achso, aber fünf gibt es ja noch, oder? Fünf Cent. Ja, eins bis vier wird abgerundet, ist nicht so schwer. Sechs bis neun wird aufgerundet, okay? Hallo. Ja, okay. Und wie du mir sagst. Ist okay. So braucht das Meeting. Ja, okay. Aber wo geht das Geld hin? Hä? Das gleicht sich ja aus. Das ist ja nicht weg. Das ist ja zu gleichen Teilen weg. Ah, nee, aber das wird doch sofort ausgenutzt. Darf nicht. Das ist das Gesetz. Bitte nicht ausnutzen. Aber dann würde ich ja so lange Sachen einkaufen, bis ich auf vier am Ende rauskomme. Weil dann spare ich ja vier. Aber dann muss ich ja mehr Geld ... Die Produkte kosten ja nur noch so viel. Produkte, die Mandarinen kosten nicht mehr 13 Cent, sondern 10 Cent. Und wenn ich die abwiege, dann rundet der Wiegeautomat automatisch auf oder ab. Das weiß ich nicht. Ja. Das heißt, ich könnte dadurch, dass ich ganz spezielle Grössen von Mandarinen nehme, wie jede Mandarine einzeln, habe jedes Mal einen Wert von 14 Cent, reduziere damit insgesamt meine Einkaufskosten um 40 Prozent, zahle also statt 10 Euro für meine Kilo Mandarinen, für 20 Kilo Mandarinen zahle ich weniger.
Und wo geht das Geld hin und wer
ersetzt es der Mandarinen-Lobby?
Das macht nämlich die
Lobby, die jetzt nicht mehr so
viel Geld herstellen muss, weil es sehr teuer ist,
ein und zwei Cent Münzen
herzustellen. Die sind ja hersteller,
viel teurer herzustellen, glaube ich,
als Scheine.
Ich glaube, das ist so.
Und da spart man ja auch eine Menge Geld an der Stelle.
Oh, wir haben übrigens, weil wir letztens
haben über Falschgeld gesprochen und über diese
Marker, wo niemand genau,
wo ich auch sehr viel
Nachrichten bekommen habe, dass
Kassierer, von Kassierinnen und Kassierern,
die alle gesagt haben, keine Ahnung,
ich habe keine Ahnung, ich mal es an, stecke es in die Kasse und everything happens. Er hat auch geschrieben, dass bei ihm auf der Arbeit, ich weiß nicht, ob er Kassierer ist oder irgendwas anderes mit Geld, jetzt so ein Weisslicht, so ein Schwarzlicht, Scanner. Und er hat auch gesagt, er hat keine Ahnung, worauf man verachten muss, er hält es in ein Schassiert es ab. So, als wäre das ... Als ob da groß draufsteht, Fälschung auf dem Schein, wenn das unter das Schwarzlicht erhält. Ja, genau. Nö, nö, nö. Nicht annehmen. So, als wäre es aber auch so wichtig, das vorher zu machen, um die Kasse zu legen. Das würde es den Schein befähigen. Ja. Man muss es kurz runterhalten. Ja. Ich würde jedes Mal ein Geräusch machen. Bip, bip. Weil die Kasse an sich auch noch nicht genug Geräusche hat. Aber da glaube ich, würde ich jeden Kunden in eine unangenehme Situation bringen, dieses Gerät und dann so. Wo haben sie denn denn her? Da habe ich gefunden. Ebay-Kleinerzeigen gefunden und dann habe ich den halt mit dahin gefahren und habe den mit dem geholt. Das ist ja ganz normal, ich weiß nicht, wo der Herrschlopf ist. Ich mache doch nur Spässe, das macht dann 14 Cent. Ach so, mach mal 15 raus. Zack! Moment, da muss 14 aufgerundet werden, auf 15. Wenn es fünf noch gibt, ach Gott, das wird ein Chaos, Leute. Und vor allem wieder leiden die leidtragenden Obdachlose. Man gibt denen doch eher ein und zwei Cent Münzen. Ja, oder die leiden dann am, oder die kriegen dann mehr. Ja. Ich hab keine, ich weiß, das ist so manche so Themen, wo ich nicht weiß, ob ich dafür dagegen bin. Doch, schon. Aber ich kenne mich ja mit dem Thema Geld nicht aus. Ich habe jetzt angefangen, den Podcast Wohlstand für alle zu hören. Ja, fantastisch. Ganz toller Podcast, sehr zu empfehlen und mit unserem lieben Freund Wolfgang M. Schmidt. Und Ole Nüman. Genau, den kann ich jetzt nicht, aber habe ich jetzt auch keinen Gern. Ganz toll, der Podcast, wo man sehr viel lernt und auch toll von diesem Expertenpodcast, dass sie anfangen, für die ganz Doven erstmal zu erklären, was ist denn überhaupt eine Bank? Wo ich mich total freue. Total gut. Ja, weil ich weiß, da sitzen zwei Männer gegenüber, rein auditiv, die sehr viel Ahnung haben jetzt von Wirtschaft und Bankwesen etc. Und ich habe keine Ahnung. Man kommt sich immer ein bisschen böse vor, wenn die dann sagen, ja, was ist denn jetzt erstmal eine Bank? Aber ich finde es ganz toll, dass sie trotzdem das machen und dass sie dann auch vorgenommen haben, einfach von Null anzufangen. Das fand ich ganz toll für mich, komplett ein Noob auf diesem Gebiet. Ne, finde ich auch, aber da merkt man mal, wie wenig Ahnung man eigentlich von einem hat. Und wie viel Angst ich jetzt auch habe. Ich habe durch diesen Podcast sehr viel Angst bekommen. Allein, weil Geld ja aus dem Nichts erschaffen wird, was ich immer nicht wusste. Ja. Oder ich bin dabei eingeschlafen dann, weil ich meistens Podcast abends höre und dann sehr müde bin und dann hat sich auch viel mit meinem Traum schon vermischt. Ja, aber das ist echt so ganz merkwürdig, aber die sind ja für Bargeld, ich weiß nicht, was die zu ein und zwei Cent machen, vielleicht machen sie dann auch eine Folge drüber, aber da war ich auch an der Kasse und dann stand ich hin. Die beiden sind für Bargeld? Ich glaube, sie haben eine Folge gemacht, wo sie die Abschaffung von Bargeld zumindest kritisch betrachten, aber ob sie jetzt, um das zu vereinfachen kann, dass sie für Bargeld ist, sind bei sich. Ja, wir sind nur eine Kack-Aussage von uns, Vollidioten, die waren schon für Bargeld, für Gargeld. Aber da stand ich letztens an der Kasse und da hat eine Dame vor mir gerade eingekauft und wurde sie vom Kassierer gefragt, Bar oder mit Karte? Und dann hat sie gesagt, ich würde gerne Bar zahlen, bevor sie uns das Bargeld auch noch abnehmen. Und es war so der, alle so. Alle gucken sich so um, auch wer nutzt es. Einfach nicht angekommen, diese Botschaft, diese, wir können einfach Schulter zucken. Wutbürgertum ist auch nicht mehr, trifft nicht mehr auf fruchtbaren Boden. Nee, gar nicht. Vor allem entweder wir beginnen jetzt ein Gespräch, das zu nichts führt, oder wir Schulter zucken uns einfach so weg. Ja, wir zucken uns weg. Die nehmen uns das auch noch weg. So dieses, das ist so ein Rundumschlag gegen alles. Wer hat uns denn was schon
weggenommen, wäre meine Frage.
Aber es ist schwierig. Ich habe mich da nicht
auf eine grosse Diskussion eingelassen.
Ich finde es, Bargeld
ist einfach die
anonymste Währung, muss man sagen.
Überhaupt. Es gibt kein anonymeren
Bargeld wie aber hier.
Ach ja, Frage. Die kleinste
Violine der Welt. Ist das Geld oder traurig? Ich formuliere die Frage um. Meint man mit dieser Reibegeste, Daumen an Zeigefinger, manchmal auch, macht der Mittelfinger noch ein bisschen mit, meint man damit ... Ganz selten der Ringfinger. Das ist ja die kleinste Violine der Welt. Ja. Da will ich schon nicht mitgehen, ehrlich gesagt.
Das stimmt. Ich formuliere die Frage noch mal andersrum.
Meint man mit dem Satz, ah, da spielt aber jemand die kleinste Violine der Welt.
Die Geste, die man macht, wenn man Geld, Moneten andeuten will, die Monetengeste.
Wir müssen jetzt halt wissen, in welchem Kontext dieser Satz geäußert wird, weil ich persönlich habe ihn noch nie gehört.
Hört man nicht so oft, nee.
Aber ich habe jetzt mal, das ist neu, ich habe in einem einem Drehbuch geschrieben, er spielt die kleinste Bühne der Welt. Und was dann, was ich im Schnitt gesehen habe, was gedreht wurde. Doppelter Rückwärtsalter. War, nee, nee genau, nee stimmt, das war, das wurde noch nicht gedreht, aber dann hat mich die Regisseurin angerufen und hat gesagt, was, wieso soll da jemand, wie traurig, wenn ich so, nee, wie klein ist die Linie der Welt, die Geldgeste, ach die Geldgeste, das ist doch nicht die Geldgeste, die kleine Linie der Welt ist, wenn jemand traurig ist und du machst dich lustig so, oh, nö, bist traurig. Jetzt hast du wieder die Geldgeste gemacht. Nee, stimmt. Ich dachte, es ist so, wenn jemand sich über etwas Nichtiges zu sehr ausheult. Das Mi-Mi-Mi-Mi. Ja, Mi-Mi-Mi-Mi, der spielt die Kleinen im Sinne von, warum dann klein? Das ist so, keine Ahnung. Ich hatte letztens mit jemandem zu tun, der nicht gebürtig Deutsch spricht, ein Amerikaner ist, aber seit Jahren in Deutschland lebt und der hat mich so ein paar Fragen gestellt, so was bedeutet das und wirklich von vier Fragen konnte ich ihm drei nicht beantworten. Fuck, ich krieg auf. So, und dann ging es so um Piment, ah Piment, was ist ein Piment? Piment.
Und ich so, pff, das ist ja, hab keine Ahnung.
Piment.
Ja, Piment, ah Piment, was ist ein Piment? Piment. Und ich so, das sehe ich ab, keine Ahnung. Piment. Ja, Piment. Und wirklich dann so Sachen, die man nicht erklären kann. Und am Ende hat er sich von mir abgewandt. Ich konnte ihm nicht weiterhelfen. Ja, aber wenn es so Fragen sind, dann ist er vielleicht schon fertig mit Deutsch auch einfach. Da kann ich nicht mehr Sprache lernen. Ja, er hat besser Deutsch gesprochen als ich, aber das sind so Dinge, Dinge fragt man so, was ist das Piment?
Und ich so, nee, brauchst du nicht. Du, ich verstehe es nicht, aber ich komme ganz gut klar mit der deutschen Sprache. Ich mache sogar einen Podcast, ich arbeite sogar mit Sprache. Also so wichtig ist es nicht. Bei vielen Worten kann man auch sagen, scheiß drauf, wirklich egal. Aber ich habe mir auch überlegt, wie viele Wörter ich in Englisch nicht kann. Geht mal durchs Haus, guckt euch mal Gegenstände an und überlegt euch mal wirklich, ob ihr, falls ihr einen wilden Abend wollt. Immer ein seltsames Bild von deinem Alltag mittlerweile. Schaut euch mal und überlegt mal, ob ihr wirklich jeden einzelnen Gegenstand auf Englisch benennen könnt. Was ist denn das hier? Ich zeige mir auch ein paar Gegenstände. Was ist denn das? Ja, Silencer.
Nee.
Die Echoer. Die Echoer.
Weiß ich nicht. Weiß ich nicht. Aber wirklich bei ganz
vielen Sachen so
Küchenutensilien,
Knoblauchpresse,
Pfannwender,
Hosenträger, so ganz viele Sachen.
Oh mein Gott. Keine Ahnung einfach.
Sock? Ja. Schuh? Ja. Jeans? Very good. Jacket? Yes, Glasses? Sofa? Glass, Microphone, Sofa? Table, coffee table. Hey, was ist das? Das ist ein Pop-Schutz. Popdefender. Yeah, you don't know it. Popdefender. You can say it. Microphone? Yes. What's this? Äh, Microphone stand. Well, can you really say that for sure? I don't know, so. Okay, I don't know. Oh, what's this? What's a Buchse? It's a podcast rack. No, what's a Buchse? It's a input, incoming cable. I don't know what it is. We don't know what it is. Braucht man nie, braucht man einfach nie. Braucht man nicht. Auch nicht so schlimm, man kann sich auch gut durchfragen. Ja. Ich bedanke mich sehr herzlich bei dir für diese Folge. Nächste Woche sind wir hier, glaube ich, in Berlin. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn ich mal wieder dabei sein darf, unter anderem nächste Woche, wo wir in Berlin sind. Sind wir da in Berlin? Am 29. Nee, stimmt nicht, übernächste Woche. 28. sind wir in Berlin. Nee, das ist nächste Woche. Nee, das ist nicht nächste Woche. Doch. Das ist nächste Woche Freitag.
Ach ja, stimmt, ich war falsch.
Ja, stimmt. Du warst falsch, ich war richtig.
Ja, nächste Woche sind wir in Berlin.
Liebe Grüße an alle, die vorbeikommen, an alle, die noch keine
Karte haben, versucht euer Glück unter dem
Hashtag PufoLive. Genau, da wird immer wieder Karten
angeboten. Und falls ihr eure Karte
abzugeben habt, aus
Gründen, die euer Bier sind.
Die wenig verstehen, euer Bier sind.
Die auch einfach unter Hashtag PufoLive.
Haut rein, vielleicht sehen wir noch ein paar von euch, würden uns
Vielen Dank. zu geben habt, aus Gründen, die eure, euer Bier sind, die wir nicht verstehen, euer Bier sind, die auch einfach unter Hashtag purforlife. Haut rein, vielleicht sehen wir noch ein paar von euch, würden uns freuen, haut rein, bis dann, macht's gut, Macht's gut, abseits vom Standard? Willkommen im Ruhrgebiet. Echt statt inszeniert.
Jede Ecke anders, jede Story echt.
Späti-Romantik an der Trinkhalle, Beats unterm Förderturm, Sonnenuntergang auf der Halde.
Klingt anders? Ist es auch.
Dein Ruhrgebiet, wo das Unperfekte perfekt passt.
Inspiration für deinen Next-Level-Städtetrip gibt's auf Insta, mein.ruhrgebiet.